على خلفيه هذه الادنى الخامسه المعلنه في
السودان كيف هو تحرك البعثات واجلاء
الرعايه حتى اللحظه
طبعا لا تستمر عمليه اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب من السودان ومن العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم في ظل هذه الظروف الامنيه المعقده
في الواقع ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه تستمر هذه
العمليه هذه خلفيه مباشره قطعه بريطانيه
حربيه رست في ميناء بورسودان طبعا تريد
المساعده في اجلاء اعداد من البريطانيين
واعداد من الرعايه الدول الاوروبيه هذه
واحده من سلسله عمليات تقوم بها قطع حربيه
يعني متعدده الجنسيات خلال الايام الماضيه
وتحاول اجلاء اعداد من الرعايه الاجانب
البعثات الدبلوماسيه خلال
الصباح الباكر في هذا اليوم تحركت او حتى
الان لم تتحرك يعني
هناك باخره على متنها اكثر من 2000 من
الرعايه الدول العربيه والاجنبيه متعدد
متعددي الجنسيات
على مدنى هذه السفينه هذه الباخره باخره
ركاب عاديه وليست قطعه حربيه ستصل الى
ميناء ميناء جده خلال اليوم
لتساعد في اجلاء اكثر من 2000 من الذين
كانوا ينتظرونا هنا في مدينه بورسودان
وتمت الاجراءات بالنسبه لهم وصعدوا جميعا
الى الى مد علمتنا هذه السفينه ستتحرك
خلال الساعات القليله القادمه الى ميناء
جده هذه هي
القطعه بريطانيه تنتظر يعني استكمال
الاجراءات بالنسبه
لهؤلاء الذين ينتظرون اجلائهم الى مدينه
جده ايضا سنحاول ان نتحرك قليلا بالصوره
لنرصد جانبا اخر ربما هو جزء من هذه
العمليه المستمره عمليه الاجلاء
بدات التي بدات خلال
سته ايام هذا اليوم السادس لهذه العمليه
هنا قريب من هذا المكان
تربط او ترسو بارجه
صينيه هذه بارجه صينيه ايضا تقوم بعمليات
الاجراءات صعود ركابها من الرعايه
الصينيين هذه هي البرجه الثالثه تدفع بها
الصين لاجلاء الرعايه الصينيين الذين يعني
بحسب الحكومه الصينيه والخارجيه الصينيه
انها
تستهدف ايلاء اكثر من 800
800 من الرعايه الصينيين هذه هي عمليه
اجلاء
مستمره وجزء من السلسله عمليات تقوم بها
الصين لاجلائي رعاياها كانت هناك بارجتان
حربيتان خلال المرحله الاولى من عمليه
الاجلاء بالنسبه للرعايه الصينيين كان على
مكان تحمل على متنها نحو 700
700 من الرعايه الصينيين الان ربما هناك
اكثر من 200 من الرعايه الصينيين يركبون
في هذه اللحظه على متن هذه البارجه
الصينيه
وعلمنا ان هناك قطعه حربيه امريكيه طلبت
الاذن من خلال لتدخل ميناء بورسودان
السلطات السودانيه هنا في مدينه
اعطتها الاذن لتصل الى مدينه خلال الساعات
القليله القادمه يتوقع وصول يعني قطعه
حربيه ايضا امريكيه بعد ان تم اعطائها
الاذن لدخول هذا الميناء هناك عمليات الى
تمت الامس هناك 52 شخص
يمثلون اعضاء في هيئات الدبلوماسيه من دول
مختلفه منهم سته عشر من السوريين يعني
وصلت بالفعل الى ميناء جده
بالامس طبعا ستتواصل هذه العمليه
بالتاكيد
وخلال مطار بورسودان الدولي وخلال ميناء
ميناء بورسودان وحتى الان هناك الاف
المنتظرين ينتظرون دورهم في انهاء عمليه
ايلائهم عبر مطار بورسودان وعبر ميناء
بورسودان ايضا شكرا لك اسامه سيد احمد كنت
معنا من بورتسود